[Music]
chuck
yes you get tired of these these
explainers of course not
i i have an unlimited i could do this
forever
jack okay i'm gonna take you up on that
i'm gonna see how long we can go all
right until you yeah until you just give
up
and jump away screaming right all right
so i got one for you
okay remember when you were a kid and
you joked about
you know you could just if you dug a
hole through the earth
like you'd come out on the other side
and here in the united states everyone
said oh you dig a hole
end up where where china and china of
course of course that was the whole idea
yeah
that was the whole idea and i remembered
like researching that when i was
early middle school i might have been in
sixth grade
so sixth or seventh grade and it was
like first of all
the center of the earth would vaporize
you so this is not a it's not a workable
thing
it's not just so given enough time i'll
dig a hole through the earth and every
time that's first point
second if you go through the earth
chances are you want to go through the
center and come out
the other side where that takes you and
going through the center
from the northern hemisphere puts you in
the southern hemisphere
and you're not in china when that
happens so in fact if you
if you do the geometry on earth's shape
dig a hole from the united states
come out the other side you end up in
the south indian ocean
oh okay which yeah yeah that's not good
you're just gonna end up flooding
america oh control the water
you just drained the indian ocean into
america so that's not good
yeah that's not good uh so but
let's imagine you could do such a thing
all right so you dig a hole through
earth
all the way through so earth's diameter
is like 8 000
miles or so so and then you look through
and like you see some light at the end
right
you got like a train person with the
flagman right
with the light and so all right
so what do you want to do next well
you got to jump in the hole now you got
to jump in the hole
i mean what else is there to do why else
do this at all
right i just dunk all the way through to
the other side of the earth
two things i'm gonna do one i'm gonna
show everybody my massive guns because
quite frankly i got jacked on that trip
that's a lot of exercise digging that
out digging that out man that's a
serious exercise
and then the second thing i want to do
is go back to where i came from
jump right back in that hole you know
all right so the funny thing is if you
actually did dig the hole
you don't have to jump through it
because you came out the other side
having successfully dug it but let's
ignore that detail as well
all right right maybe she had some
device that plowed through like a
like a a pineapple corer right it just
goes through it comes out
there's the hole so now watch now you
jump in
okay uh let me describe what happens
i know if you ever thought about this so
there's at all times a force of gravity
between you
and earth manifested from earth's center
and any amount of earth that is outside
of your radius
from the center of the earth has no
net effect on how much you weigh
or what the force is that's accelerating
you
so in other words it's brilliant this is
it's a brilliant you can demonstrate
this as an early physics 101
using newton's laws of gravity so watch
what happens as you as you fall in
there is earth on the other side of you
pulling at you right
there's like the center of the earth and
all the earth from there to china okay
or
the indian ocean but then there's the
earth above your head
trying to pull you back right
okay it turns out that even though
you're getting
closer to parts of the earth on the
other side
and farther from the parts of the earth
that are above your head
the net force of each of those sides of
the earth exactly cancel on you
and the only thing that matters is how
much earth is between your feet and the
center of the earth
sphere that's between the bottom of your
feet
and the center of the earth that's the
only net gravitational force pulling on
you
and since that is getting less and less
and less
the force of gravity on you is becoming
less and less and less
and so your weight if you like paused
and weighed yourself
you would start weighing less and less
and less until you got to the center
where you weigh zero nothing nothing
however however
this whole time you have been
accelerating accelerating right
so you've been moving faster and faster
and faster by
a lower and lower force of gravity but
your speed continues to increase
and you hit a maximum speed at the
center of the earth
so even though you don't weigh anything
and nothing's pulling on you
you overshoot yeah and you overshoot by
exactly the right speed to
perfectly make it out of the hole on the
other side
uh because the further you get away from
the center the greater the gravity would
become the
start slowing you down it's a breaking
you it's up it starts to break it
uh on the way in it speeds you up on the
way out it slows you down
and it's a perfect ignoring air
resistance and monsters in the center
you know right and the more locks and
right
the middle earth people the middle ears
and the chuds
got to remember the chuds
all the creatures that that lurk in the
center the earth ignoring them
that they don't want to eat you and the
air resistance and all that it's an
exactly
symmetric journey the speed up to the
middle
the drop in your weight as you pass
through the middle till it's zero
the increase in your weight and the and
the overshooting
the decrease and right when you get to
the other side
if nobody grabs you you'll fall back
down the hole
so you got to make sure somebody gets
somebody's
you need a you need a spotter somebody's
got to catch somebody
gotta be gotta catch you okay so now
that journey you know how long that
journey takes
no this is eight thousand miles eight
thousand miles eight thousand miles uh
take it out
okay uh i'm gonna say
um i don't know an hour and a half how
do i have this nice that's nice nice
guess
no but it's a nice guess uh it takes 45
minutes
wow 45 minutes so you can easily
wait that one out right yeah uh you know
so
and it required no other than the effort
to dig the hole
the traveling the eight thousand miles
was completely exploiting the force of
gravity gravity
not only to speed you up but also to
slow you down you didn't need brakes oh
my god it's
the best log flume ride ever
exactly
cross your arms and go for it good go
for it exactly
so uh so now uh
so let's say nobody does grab you and
then you come back so then you'll emerge
how many minutes later back where you
started
uh 45 minutes another 45 minutes so 45
minutes plus 45 minutes
there's your hour and a half there's an
hour and a half so now round trip the
round trip is an hour and a half to get
back to where you work by the way
that's the same amount of time it takes
for a satellite to
orbit the earth oh snap
oh oh
that is awesome oh that takes a z-snap
on that one
yeah because it's in free fall it's in
free fall the entire way
both entire ways did that's amazing it's
amazing and you do this in like physics
101 and you've come to out the end of
the equation and it's like
wow that is deep and that's fun to know
so you you so one goes sideways 17 000
miles an hour you're in orbit
one just drops in you you do a high five
as you cross on the other side and then
you come back
and you meet again so that's a low earth
orbit
we'll get you that so now if you don't
want to use fuel to get from any one
place to another
what happens if you just simply dug
holes between
any pair of places on earth whether or
not you go through the center
so here we are on the east coast let's
dig a hole through the earth to
california
it won't go through the center of the
earth no because it'll just it'll
cut through sort of sideways a little
bit all right but it's still a hole
all right how long will that take if you
do the math
it turns out any hole through the earth
across any distance between any two
points is 45 minutes
ladies and gentlemen meet the concept of
the gravity train
dig a hole between any two points and
it'll take you 45 minutes to gr you do
the math it's 45 minutes
so it's not useful to go from like
you know jersey to manhattan even
you might as well just get in a car and
do that because the whole
this doesn't work the hole's got to get
deep and all right so here's a problem
if it goes through the center of the
earth you
you can just jump in you don't need
tracks but if you're sort of
not going through the center of the
earth you need a really low friction
rail system that you can fall in on and
so you need low friction because
friction will eat up your energy and
then you won't make it to the other side
right so that's a gravity train that's
what happens if you jump through again
ignoring the middle earth creatures the
monsters the troll
the you know the the undersea trolls and
all the rest
and all right and of course the chuds
because there goes the neighborhood once
you see them
so i i hope i settled that for you that
is cool man
back to elementary school for you yeah
well i i wish they had taught me that in
elementary school i might
then what would you have done i might be
a scientist now
this is a lament
okay if only they had taught me about
the gravity train damn it
so but what happened is you the whole
world becomes swiss cheese
right and how would you get the hole
through the magma you know all the
places that feed volcanoes
you know there are details that are not
entirely worked out but
in principle this can work for example
if you had a completely
dead moon with no plate tectonics or
anything
because you don't want like continental
plates to shift while you're on route
closing the hole guys uh
looks like we got a road closure up
ahead guys
um fortunately that means we're all
gonna die and uh that's it
you know we're stuck with the with the
middle earth monsters
yes so all right that's all that's all
i love it that's that's a very cool
thing that's all you got here all right
thanks chuck for
hanging with me absolutely keeping that
spirit i'm neil degrasse tyson
to keep
you